Rod's hey what's up guys it's rob and
welcome to my tutorial for the exploding
stick bomb today I'm going to show you
how to make the exploding stick bomb and
although it might sound like it's
dangerous because of the word exploding
it's actually really safe it's fun and
it's easy to make I would just recommend
that you wear a pair of safety glasses
like these that I got at a local
hardware store that way in case things
do pop up they don't go into your eye
there's many different types of stick
bombs this one is known as the Cobra
weave because of the pattern that it
makes when you put it together stick
bombs are in the category of crafts
known as kinetics because stick bombs
are really a lesson in physics kinetic
energy is the energy of motion when you
take a rubber band and you stretch it
when you hold it like this it has what's
called potential energy but when you let
it go it turns into kinetic energy or
the energy of motion the same thing
applies to the stick bomb for this
tutorial you're going to need craft
sticks these are the same sticks that
you find in a dental office when they do
the interaural exam they're known as
tongue depressors but you could find
these online on Amazon on eBay I believe
I got a box of 500 for about eight
dollars you might be able to find it an
even better deal now but I would
definitely not recommend using popsicle
sticks some people have been asking
about those and they're thinner they're
very thick and they don't bend as nicely
as the craft sticks do so I would HIGHLY
advise that you use these instead so
once you have the eyewear and also the
sticks you're ready to go we're going to
start off by grabbing a handful of
sticks as you'll see I'm doing the
tutorial on a carpet because the carpet
is softer and more compressible than a
hard floor it easily allows us to add
the sticks to one another by sliding
them underneath like that which doesn't
mean you can't do it on a harder floor
it'll just make things more tricky so I
would recommend starting or trying it on
a carpet first we're going to start up
by taking two sticks and you'll see I've
labeled one U and one D you don't have
to do this I just did it for
demonstration the U stands for up and
the D stands for down so there's two
different types of sticks that we work
with when we make this stick bomb up
sticks and down sticks
we're going to start out by taking one
stick in my case which is our first down
stick and we're going to put it on the
carpet just like that at an angle up to
the right now we're going to take the
first up stick and we're going to put it
on top of the down stick and when I do
that I am NOT putting it at a 90 degree
angle like this
I want the up stick and the down stick
ends to be pretty close together just
about like that
maybe it's the the length of my thumb is
the distance between them you don't want
them too close together and you don't
want them too far apart so you want it
right about there these two angles
should basically be about fifty degrees
so that their acute now the way that we
add sticks to these two sticks is we
start with the left and then we add to
the right then we add to the left and
then we add to the right so to first add
our first stick we're going to push down
in the middle of these two take the
third stick now and as you'll see this
is the down stick this is the stick
that's on top or the up stick we're
going to put the third stick underneath
the down stick and on top of the up
stick we're basically going to slide it
over this one and under this one sort of
like we do in my ninja star tutorials so
we're basically going to put it
underneath the the damn stick and on top
of the up stick just like that and then
what you want to do is you're going to
slide the tip of the stick here down
like this until it starts to kind of
come out here so you don't want to
basically go down here like that until
it pops out you're going to slide it
underneath and you can probably get it
to right about there now at this point
we're going to hold here on the left so
we first added a stick to the left now
we're going to add to the right and as
you'll see this is still the down stick
and this is now our new up stick so
we're basically going to do the same
thing that we did here on this side take
another stick this is the down stick so
we slide the tip of this stick here
underneath the down stick you don't want
to slide it all the way out like that
you're just putting the tip underneath
and then you're sliding it on top
of the up stick now in this case what we
want to do with this one is rotate it
until it is completely parallel or
running along the same line as this up
stick that we first had okay so now
these two sticks should be parallel now
that we added this one we could
basically hold down or push down on the
on top of the up stick here so now we
edit to the right we're going to add
again to the left this was our first up
stick but as you'll see it's now
underneath this one so that makes it a
down stick this is our new up stick so
the same way that we added this one to
these two we're going to add this stick
by putting it underneath this one here
which is now the the down stick slide it
underneath the down stick and put it on
top of the new up stick here and slide
it across until the direction of this
one is in the same direction as the tip
that's here okay so I haven't really
slid it under there enough so let me
tuck it there and now I'm going to hold
with my left hand right there so we're
that's basically what we do we add to
the left the right the left and now
we're going to add to the right here's
the down stick and here is our new up
stick slide the tip of the new stick
underneath the down stick and on top of
the up stick you don't want to slide it
underneath like this it needs to be
underneath the down stick and on top of
the up stiff if it's easier for you what
you can do is kind of insert it like
this okay that way you can see that it's
going on top of this one and underneath
this one and you just want to put the
tip of it remember you don't want to
slide it too much like that okay
so make sure that these two are now
parallel so they should look parallel
these two should be parallel these two
should be parallel okay and then just to
keep adding you hold down here on the
right so keep adding put one underneath
the down stick and on top of the up
stick
and that's basically how you add the
sticks together and make the stick bomb
now you're asking how do I stop or how
do I let go basically because if I let
this go the whole thing is going to come
apart so what you do is you take the
last stick that you added which is the
latest up stick this is the newest up
stick that we have and this is the down
stick which is right next to it okay so
this is basically where we would be
adding if we want it to continue but if
you want to stop you take the up stick
and you shift it down so that the tip of
it here is underneath the down stick
that's right next to it so you kind of
lift it up and you slide it underneath
like that so make sure it's it's still
underneath this one and you just slide
it down until it is underneath this down
stick and that's basically how you add
them together now at this point you'll
see that we can kind of move this around
and when you're working on carpet when
you interlock them together it gets
stuck on the carpet so it's basically
just pulling those hairs out so now we
can do is if I want to continue adding I
can kind of shift this around I can move
it around it's not going to come apart
unless you know this pops out bring it
down and now say I want to keep adding
so what I do remember this is the latest
up stick this is the last stick that we
added so you're going to hold down here
okay and you're going to basically take
this one out now where do we add well
we add here here's the down stick and
here's the up stick so I'm going to hold
here take a new stick put it underneath
the down stick and on top of the up
stick hold here take a new stick put it
underneath the down stick on top of this
up stick all right hold here take a new
stick put it underneath the down stick
on top of the up stick now again if I
want to stop all I have to do is to take
the latest up stick the last one that I
just put in and just slide it down and
put the tip of it underneath the down
stick that's right next to it
all right so that's basically how you
make the stick bomb once you really get
the hang of it then you should be able
to do it pretty quickly
so like I said before at this point you
need to basically lift up the entire
stick bomb
all around the carpet to make sure that
it's not connected to it
what you do is you hold the stick bomb
and you're going to take out the first
stick that you put in which is the down
stick alright so here it goes
hold on to the rest of this stick bomb
Lila you better watch out and then you
let it go move we left I like to thank
you guys very much for watching the
tutorial and for being so patient for me
to get it out I have a lot of other
ideas for tutorials that I'm going to do
as soon as I can I'm not going to say
soon because I do have a lot of work to
catch up on in school but definitely
keep an eye out on the weekends that's
really when I have some time to do
things again just be safe wear glasses
with this because you never know when
things can pop out and I like to give a
big thanks to my friend Dane he was the
one who recommended that I make the
tutorial for this and he was also one
who bought me two sticks so thank you
very much Dane as always leaving a
comment below and be sure to check out
my store you know if you do like my
shirt this is currently the only one
that I have but I'm definitely going
making some more when I come up with the
design so I post a link below and if you
guys do post a video response with
yourself wearing my shirt you never know
I'll actually I would definitely include
it in my next video thanks again for
watching the video if you did enjoy it
be sure to click the thumbs up or the
like button down below and subscribe to
my videos by clicking the subscribe
button above I hope everyone had a happy
fourth of July and got to see some cool
fireworks on my way back here to Philly
from Long Island I actually saw some
fireworks but I also saw a cool
lightning storm which I actually had to
drive through so maybe it wasn't so cool
but I have some footage of that and I'm
putting it on my Rob's phone channel
right after I upload this tutorial you
can find the video by clicking on this
link up here and I'll see you next time